こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さん
また
またやばい人が現れましたはいというわけ
でここ今僕が住んでいる3億円のはじめ
しゃちょーの豪邸なんですけれども結構
目立つ家というか形が独特だしこのお家で
たくさん動画撮ったのでたくさんの人が
このお家の構造とか何階建てかとかどこに
どういう部屋があるかというのが結構
分かっていらっしゃっていただきまして
すごい敬語になったな僕が動画たくさん
出したのでたくさんの方がこの家の構造を
知ってて最近この家ですねゲームで完全
再現方がいらっしゃったんですよ
クオリティやばかったです動画あります
概要欄から是非見てみてください今回は
ちょっとまた違う方向でやばい人が現れ
ました皆さんはレゴというものをご存知
でしょうかレゴ僕も子供の頃遊んだんです
けどもこうブロックをくっつけて何か物を
作ったり動物作ったりドラゴン作ったり
なんかこう建物建物
はいもうおわかりでしょうなんとですね
その子わずか10歳10歳にしてはじめ
しゃちょーの3億円のオチを作った子が
いるらしいです
10歳って俺何してたんだろ10歳俺何だ
カブトムシ捕まえてましたよそれもさ
なんかさ10歳の子が作るからなんか
初めて
ですよよいしょできた
みたいななんか単純な作りではなく
Twitterでちょっと話題になってた
んでさらっと見たんですけれども
[音楽]
めっちゃ再現度が高いえこれ本当に10歳
の方が作ったんですかと相当細かい部分
まで断って作っていたので
めっちゃびっくりして本当に13歳の子が
作ったのかと思って直接その子のご両親に
ご連絡させていただきましてその子のお家
に行って実物を今回
貸していただきましたありがとうござい
ますこうた君っていう男の子なんですけど
もその子もすごい喜んでくれててなんと
実物が今お家にありますでもらいに行った
時に色々もらったんだ
可愛いお菓子の詰め合わせもらってこっち
はもう光沢がプレゼントしてくれたミニ
初め社長のおうちみたいなこのフィギュア
マジでありがとう
めっちゃ大事にするすごいよこの時点で
もうちょっと皆さん感じてもらっていい
ですかもうねあのー
素人じゃないんですよ作りが素人じゃない
んですよこれ3向けのお家だと思うんです
けどなんかこういう細かい建物の構造とか
も完璧に作ってる感じこの時点でこの方は
ちょっとこの子はただものじゃないとあお
手紙も書いてくれたはじめしゃちょーさん
へはじめしゃちょーに僕の作品を見て
もらえてとても嬉しいですそして実際に
会えるなんて夢みたいです記念にミニ
シャツはハウスを作りました是非家に飾っ
てみてくださいこれからも応援してます
幸田よりかわいいかわいいけどやってる
ことえげつないんよなんかお話聞くと
なんかレゴのそういうなんかショーとかも
受賞してるマジのなんかレゴビルダーの
男の子で実際の取り扱い説明書をもらった
ので説明がしっかり書いてあるんですけど
ちょっと実際に10歳の少年が作った
はじめしゃちょーの3億円のお家でご飯見
てみたいと思います
さあ持ってきましたよさあ持ってきました
この中に少年がはじめ社長の動画を何度も
見て自らの手で作ってくれたレゴの家が
あります早速見てみましょう
[音楽]
あーやばい言葉を失ったわ今どうやって
取り出そうかなこれえ俺取り出す時に壊し
たら普通に俺多分結構自分留めたいんだ
けど
ちょっと皆さんどうやって出せばいいです
かえどうやって出そうこれこれ出す雪ねえ
な
ダンボール壊します
持ち上げてガシャーンてなったらマジでや
だからダンボール壊す道を選ぶわ俺段
ボール壊させていただきます
俺の命に代えて実際の男の子が作ってくれ
たレゴ出すことができましたでは
ご覧くださいどうぞ
はいみなさんこれが実際の男の子が作った
はじめしゃちょーさんの豪邸でハウスです
よいい意味で怖いよこれ本当に外観パッと
見でやっぱり俺んちだってわかるんですよ
ねこれで角度ねいや外観やばいよねこれ
もうこれオレンジの玄関だもん普通にこの
青いのも全く同じ色合いですグレート黒に
なってるここら辺の色合いもね全く一緒で
ちゃんとこの駐車場が斜めになってるのを
レゴで表現できるんだここの草もちゃんと
毛が生えてるんですよこここういうのが
このちょっとちょっと雨宿りできる屋根が
あるのも一緒ここの鉄格子の感じも全く
一緒
ヤシの木の本数も一緒です螺旋階段も完璧
に作られてるしこうねおもろいのが多くに
これはじめしゃちょーの鉄道がちゃんと
置いてあるんですよ
すごいなぁちゃんとスマホも持ってるし
ここまで細かく見れるで前庭もねちゃんと
このガーデンというか庭みたいな感じに
なってるのも完璧に再現できてます2階の
このスペースねここも完璧に再現できて
ます
でこっちに行って2階のこのスペースも
完璧でこっちから入るここも知ってんのね
ここの入り口もちゃんとしてるんだすごい
な裏庭もしっかり作られてるしはちゃんと
象の歯磨き粉の後でハゲた場所も再現して
ますあもうゴミ捨てる場所もそんな再現し
てるこれも普通にあるんですよすごいな
おい俺車あるぞオリジナルかな
ガレージ本当はねこっちなんだけどここら
辺ちょっとあんまり動画で映さないから
わかんないからこの角度とかマジですごい
あーポリスポリス
シェルシェル石油ここら辺ちょっと10歳
の男の子っぽいかな
待って待って待ってちょっと待って
ください皆さんこれ中も
完璧かこれちょっと待ってマジで怖い今2
階のキッチンになったよなちょっと中行き
ましょうかあこれちゃんと廊下が見えてる
あすごいあああ
めっちゃ俺ん家だ
めっちゃオレンジここすごいよここマジで
オレンジの廊下です
これだいぶ研究してるで1回で見ただけ
じゃここまでクオリティ高くできないと
思うんだよしじゃあこのうちの4回見て
いきたいと思います天井外せるはい
あーこうやって板を作るんだすごいな勉強
になるわ
おすごい
[音楽]
ここが
4階のあのベランダね
4階のベランダ完璧ですえすごいこれあれ
か
世界で作る部屋だすげー明らか黒いもんな
世界黒い部屋がちゃんとありますでここお
風呂場を作られてるシャワーも付いてるし
ちゃんと蛇口うちあるんですよ4階に
見えるこの窓
富士山見える窓もしっかりと作られてて
[音楽]
大好き君の部屋ですねすごいな
でここが
この机あるこのL字の机あるよ
配信する場所でしょカメラも置いてある
机まで一緒なんだよこれいやすごいよこれ
いやこれすごいよ
めっちゃ細かく見てるこれ4階の間取りと
かもかなり忠実に再現されてますじゃ次3
回見ていきましょう3階はなんか寝室とか
コンビニ部屋とかがある場所だね行きます
よ
はい3
階ですを寝室もちゃんとあるね
階段しっかりあってそうねここショーツが
ある部屋でも表現できてるな
障子っぽいガチャッと開けてこうコンビニ
ベっとこれ多分コンビニの棚を表現したん
だろうなすごいなぁじゃあ次2回行きます
2回オープン
にはいこれ2階ですここも
廊下がしっかり再現されてて
ドアドアこれ開けるとそのままですこれ大
広間があるんですよこっち側にえ待って
待って
もうロッカー分かれてるのえ結構最近じゃ
なかったロッカー置いたのもうロッカー
設置されてんだけどすごい速いめっちゃ
最新の俺の家こっちに
出す和室ですねテレビ置いてる和室がある
とってことはこの広間の奥にキッチンが
あるはずなんだけども
キッチンが
このおしゃれなキッチンも再現椅子もあり
ますちゃんと
椅子ちゃんとこの水出るやつもあるし
コーラたくさん買ったやつもちゃんとこれ
置いてあるえティッシュだから助かるいや
こことかマジで一緒なんですよもうこの
キッチンとコーラの感じとかすごい
めっちゃ細かく見てるこの窓ガラスガラス
張りとかも表現できてるのがまたすごいね
続いて1回いきましょうか
優しくとるぜはい
おーこれさっきの入り口ねさっきの入り口
ここ入ってここから出てきてうわすげえ
入口の門
完全にあるまさか開くあくのねすげえ
オレンジのも完全再現ですでここ入ると
[音楽]
植物もちゃんとあるしこの植物ちゃんと家
にもあるんですよ
完璧
トイレもあるホテルでここがあここは
光沢の中では
俺ちょっと金庫になってるのかなでこっち
がいつも俺がいる部屋だね今まさに動画を
撮っている机がこれかで裏のあものを置く
スペースもちゃんとあるこの茶色い机が
まさにこれでこのソファーがまさにそれ
ですすごいカエルのレゴあるんだ
絶対これピチューだこのチーズみたいなの
絶対ピチューだこれ絶対こうた君この
ピッチで表現してくれたねとりあえず
[音楽]
命に代えてても戻すなんか見たけど結構
触っちゃったけどこれ戻せるんかなよし
よし完璧あオッケーオッケー良かった無事
に戻せてよし戻せましたちょっとこれ壊す
のだけはマジでよかったいやー
感動しましたこうた君の説明いろいろ書い
てあるんだけど後ろにポリスとかシェルっ
て書いてあったのこれ別に光沢君が10歳
の男の子っぽいとかじゃなくて家が大き
すぎてパーツが足りなかったんだって
パーツが足りなくても他のこういう白いの
使うしかなかったみたいな感じでてことは
これパーツだけあればもうちょっと後ろと
かも真っ白にできたってことかこれで多分
なんだけど1回や2回動画見てるレベル
じゃないと思うんですよ何回も初めて社長
のお家を使った動画を見てどこに何がある
かとかお家の作りとかこれぐらいのサイズ
感なんじゃないかとか実際に初めて来た
わけじゃないのにこんなに作れ
るってめっちゃ
研究したと思うんですよすごいマジで
すごい行動力ありがとう
めっちゃ嬉しいはいというわけでわずか
10歳にして初めて社長のお家を作りきっ
てしまう少年やばい男の子が出てきたわけ
なんですけれどもすごいななんか俺んちの
使い方いろいろあるな俺が家で何かすると
かじゃなくてこの他の人いろんな人が俺ん
ちをいじってくれてめっちゃ楽しいんで
よかったら是非また
譲ってくれる方募集しております今回は
マジですごかったこれ作るのにどんぐらい
かかったんだろうちょっと電話してみよう
かな
あお疲れ様です
お伺いしてもいいですか
作るのにどれくらいかかったんですか
何日ぐらいかかったかなとあなるほど
じゃあすいませんありがとうございます
はいすいませんありがとうございます
失礼します
父さんも把握してないんだこれやっぱ
こうた君こっそり作ってるから家族の人も
きっとわかんないんだよどれくらいかかっ
たかめっちゃ時間かかったと思うよ本当に
これは俺が作るとしたらこれ多分前庭だけ
で2日かかるから
どうやってヤシの木作るのすごいななんか
見れば見るほど味があるというか感動する
なこれあもしもしもしもしお疲れ様ですお
疲れ様です
そうですね3日間ぐらい3日
[音楽]
そうですねちょっと学校帰りで学校から
帰ってきて作って
集中してやってました
ありがとうございます本当に素敵な作品を
とんでもないですありがとうございます
失礼いたします
[音楽]